United Nations Secretary General is
warning of looming famine in Somalia as
it faces its worst drought in decades
Antonio guterres says climate change has
created chaos he's imploring the
International Community to act
humanitarian assistance is needed for
some 8.3 million somalis and we must now
act to prevent a catastrophe the 2023
humanitarian response plan which seeks
2.6 billion US dollars is just 15
percent funded
when famine looms this is totally
unacceptable
Al jazeera's Catherine Sawyer reports
from baidawa
the U.N Secretary General has visited
Somalia many times before because of
drought and violence but this time the
drought is worse
five rainy seasons have failed in the
Horn of Africa Somali is the most
affected more than 40 000 people have
died in the last one and a half years
many more have had to leave their homes
Terrace is here to call for much needed
humanitarian support we have launched an
appeal to the International Community
only 15 percent of that appeal has been
funded until now the International
Community has been absent-minded in
relation to the drama of the people of
Somalia it's time to look seriously into
these people that is suffering too much
is badly hit many somalis are coming
here from different areas but help in
the camps is limited
some are also fleeing conflict as the
government carries out an offensive
against the armed group al-shabab
president Hassan Sheikh Muhammad says
his government is winning the war
at the moment we're working together
with other International Partners this
stabilization program of the post
al-shabab or deliberated areas this we
look to the U.N to increase critical
investment in these areas as these
people as our citizens has been denied
the accessibility of civils services for
long time
the Army has taken back important areas
held by the group for many years
Ultra Bob is still able to carry out a
talks and scare people
Gutierrez visit shows a glimpse of how
uncertain things are here
Mogadishu was partially locked down
major roads were closed and no one was
Taking Chances but that uncertainty is a
life of many somalis who call this home
we can now speak to Catherine soy joins
us live from Mogadishu so the UN
Secretary General also calling for
massive International support for
Somalia any sign the world is responding
to that call
[Applause]
well the Secretary General has was here
for two days and he held a press
conference earlier today and basically
he's here to ramp up this humanitarian
efforts
um because he's saying many many people
in Somalia are suffering so we went with
him to a region uh in the southwest
where thousands of people are making
their way to that area in baidoa just
trying to get help but then the
assistance there is very very unlimited
and people are living rough so the
Secretary General basically uh had a
conversations with people who are
displaced there about their needs which
are massive uh and he also called on the
internet the International Community to
do more to avert a farming because
thousands of people 40 000 people
actually have died in the last one and a
half years the Secretary General also
held talks with the president about the
you know the security the security
situation in the country we have been
talking to many somalis uh who is saying
that beyond the aid beyond the help that
they need they want to see more in terms
of measures of resilience because a lot
of somalis are saying that they need to
break away from this cycle of violence
and drought that we have seen for so
many years
all right thanks so much Catherine soy